Jimmy Patterson didn't inherit money he
made it
the billionaire from BC rose from humble
beginnings selling garden seeds
door-to-door and at age 91 remains one
of the world's most successful
entrepreneurs I had the best parents you
could ever get but the only thing we
didn't have was money but that didn't
affect anything his work ethic is
notorious he's delivered newspapers
worked on trains washed cars and always
dreamed big
the first business he bought was a car
dealership in Vancouver and he's never
let his foot off the gas the Jim
Patterson group is the second largest
privately held company in Canada and
it's into everything cars signs
agricultural equipment grocery stores
wine stores radio stations forest
products fishing real estate theme parks
and even the Guinness Book of World
Records operation about 48,000 employees
more than ten billion dollars in annual
sales I have fun going to work every day
everybody's different I just prefer
going to work I like what I do and so I
just keep doing it
he shares his wealth has given millions
to BC hospitals including 75 million to
build a new hospital in Vancouver the
largest donation from a private citizen
to a single medical facility in Canadian
history I got to get up and pay for all
this stuff not know I do have to go to
work
mr. Patterson thank you so much for
talking to us tell me how you're coping
in this pandemic what's your greatest
worry I don't have a worry thing so
eventually we will come out find
overtime this is a big hit that we've
had hits before but nothing like this
but we'll come out of it but it will
take time you've got how many divisions
25 I think if I got that right yeah we
have 24 25 different divisions yeah a
very broad range of companies and
interests you sound pretty optimistic
about the future of all of them would
you say oh no we got trouble we have
some that are doing very well because
some that are doing very bad but over
time things will get back to I think a
new normal and because certainly a lot
of things that we're doing today some of
this is going to stick and that we do
and so but long term we'll be fine
long term meaning one year two years
five years well my guess uneducated yes
is probably take two years for we get
back to their some kind of normal what
we think is normal what will be
different by something are you talking
about your own companies now or you mean
the about my opinion yeah uneducated
well you know you have a lot of
expertise a lot of experience decades of
course of running successful companies
have you ever seen a storm like this
never ever seen anything like it nor has
anybody else you know there are some
people who say like Bill Gates for
example who sort of warned about
something like this happening did you
see it coming did you were you able to
put anything in place in your companies
to sort of weather
absolutely not blindsided like everybody
else well we certainly never imagined
anything as as deep as this in the
change of the way we get up in the
morning and think about things and
economies around the world effectively
shut down they certainly a huge huge hit
no question about it you know the United
States is particularly hard-hit I think
the numbers yesterday were 36 million
yes unemployed which is almost the
population of Canada and there it's the
worst unemployment numbers since the
depression yeah what's your concern
about the global economy and where it
might be headed do you think it could be
headed towards well certainly when it
gets back to whatever is the new normal
which will will take some time there's a
lot of a lot of smart people out there
and a lot of people that that will move
be leaders to take us to the new the new
next step that we have here and long
term I'm optimistic well that's good to
know
that's good to know what has been the
impact on how you do business well
everything is different the food
business is different than the
automobile business or your business
they're broadcasting and but with with
technology and and the knowledge that we
have today there will be a lot of new
things coming up you have I think 48,000
employees
roughly yes something like that are they
all okay well you I'm not sure that I'm
not aware of anything that was seriously
we have people are that have have got
the virus in various parts of our some
of our people not in Vancouver
particularly but in our whole system and
it's all being dealt with where we
prepare for our
people are prepared for it and different
divisions and and but it's it's not out
of control or anything like that but we
do you have a lot of people who work in
the food industry and grocery stores and
food distribution who are now essential
workers we have and I've only heard of
one person that we've had a problem like
that do you think it's given us a new
appreciation for all those people though
who do that kind of absolutely the
contribution that these caregivers have
have contributed to a situation like
we're in is is really special and they
deserve so much appreciation and thanks
from the rest of us that aren't in that
business and I guess people who work in
grocery stores - right well the grocery
store people there anybody dealing with
people yeah or but our people have put a
lot of effort into making sure that that
to the best of our ability that we
follow all the rules and regulations or
washing your hands and the distance that
we're talking about and but you can get
it from your neighbor or walking the dog
or somebody yeah close enough is Canada
better position do you think in some
other countries to come through this I
don't know about Canada because I think
there's so much difference between let's
say Vancouver Island and Montreal that I
think I think there's every location is
not necessarily country but geography
and the attitude of the people are very
different in one country and so I think
you have to take a sort of region by
region so the best you can some people
really play ball and do the right thing
right away and are discipline other
people are much less easygoing more
easygoing yeah less discipline yeah and
what about economically in terms of sort
of the global economy as can
in in in a good position do you think
relative to other countries well boy
we're putting a lot of depth on the
country as our is certainly people like
the Americans and that this will be I
can't answer your question I'm not smart
enough to know just where all this debt
finally ends up the long long term will
be fine but just where the hits are I'm
not sure do you you know there's been a
lot of life lines being given by the
federal government to businesses and to
individuals right that's what you're
referring yes yeah do you think that has
been necessary and well I think it's
been I do think it generally speaking
it's they've done what they think is
best a long term because you got to deal
with the people they're being affected
but the the debt that goes that they're
putting on somewhere there's a price to
pay for all of that
yeah but right now the people in
authority are making the best decision
that they can with the best advice they
got and we got to support that well yeah
the calculation is to shut down big
parts of the economy in order to save
lives right absolutely and do you think
there's there's it's clear what the
choice is there well absolutely and the
number one thing you got to protect is
people's lives and there's a lot of
there's a if you open up too fast it's
going to it's going to cause more deaths
and so you have to give in my opinion
you have to give the priority to making
sure people stay alive
I think that's number one and then you
do the best you can by the same token
people lose their jobs by the thousands
hundreds of thousands as and we need to
get back as fast as we can but in my
opinion not at the risk of a bunch more
deaths are you following the public
health briefings I do
well I'd follow it on the news yeah yeah
listening to people like you well that's
good I appreciate that who do you think
is
what do you think of the of the
leadership of the role of science and
the public health officers as we go
through this well I think that they're
terrific I think they're hugely
dedicated people and very conscientious
and very helpful and useful at this time
there are some business leaders who have
think they have some expertise in that
area I'm talking about Elon Musk in
particular I don't know if you've heard
what he'd said but that the corona virus
is a dumb panic that you know we should
get on with opening up businesses do you
think there's a business should be
business and public health should be
public health and you shouldn't pretend
to be an expert in well I did I said if
I were it was up to me I would focus to
the best of my ability to protect the
people and their health and reduce the
risk of death whatever that takes and
then on the other side you got all these
people that are out of work and so we
have to do that the leaders have a
difficult job today you know you have so
many different divisions in your company
is that been part of the secret to
resilience is diversity your strength
when you have Isis today yeah we are
diversified and it's been very useful to
be diversified in a situation like this
for us
we have businesses doing very very well
and we have others are doing very very
bad W had to lay off many people we have
had to layoff people does that how much
does that pain you that's not only
depends
it is sometimes some of our people are
making more money from what they're
getting from the government that we were
paying them so they're not hurting those
people yeah and how how likely are you
to come back to the same strength do you
think that you know we're willing into
overtime
yeah I'm so optimistic I will be doing
things differently then we have so what
do you mean by that
do you see that playing out how you will
do things differently well it depends on
the industry I mean so and the location
certainly if you're in Quebec it's
different than if you're in Saskatchewan
and and it depends what industry if
you're in the food business is very
different than if you're in the lumber
business yeah so take maybe the food
business how do you think do you think
we'll continue to operate in grocery
stores the way we are now or we will
there's that'll be it'll it'll change
the grocery stores are different today
than they were 25 years ago so there's
always changed yeah yeah this is going
to speed up some of it I guess that's a
lesson you learn after years in business
that change is good right you don't have
to be afraid of it change is inevitable
and it's the key is to sometimes change
yeah you have to it's disappointing and
you have to make some changes but anyway
changes with us ever since time began
what's your advice on how to make a
business more resilient in the event
there was another pandemic well I think
that George Bush George George W Bush
the son when he was president he said
the important thing is to get ready for
these kinds of events because if you
don't get ready it's too late when it
happens and he was absolutely right and
when I remembered in fact I got a video
on it that where he actually spoke and
said it's too late if you don't prepare
ahead of time for these kinds of crises
that come along hard to prepare for
something like it is right I mean the
scale of this is it is it's kind of but
people in the health business they
understand all these things certainly
better than people like me and they have
played a huge role in what's happening
today on a very positive basis as you
know you know there's some people who
think including public health officers
that the United States is our biggest
risk right
now our proximity to the US do you have
views on when you think the canada-us
border should open no I don't the
experts will have the they'll have the
information it's certainly from a
business point of view the quicker the
better but it may not be the best for
the population and depends on the part
of the country again as I said the
experts will have to decide that does
having that border shut to everything
except a non-essential business affect
your business Oh everything yeah
everything affects our business as it
relates to the policies they're having
we have as you said we've got 48
thousand employees and we're in
different businesses at different
locations we have people and in New
Brunswick and Nova Scotian we've got
people in Victoria and everywhere in
between and the United States and we
have a min London England and we have
people in our company that that work in
China and Japan so it's every situation
is a bit different
you have always remained a privately
owned company is that been better
no I gotta had I have been in the pub we
still are we're involved with with a
couple of company a couple of public
companies okay
but we haven't always been we've been
but we've always been private at some
point and and it just gives us a little
bit more freedom to do things well
that's what I wondered about so does
that give you is that make you more
resilient now does it give you the
ability to look longer term or I think
well certainly if you're private it you
could may you can move very quickly and
we don't have a lot of the things that
go with being a public company and it's
just more difficult and more expensive
in a public company and but in our case
we
we just have a conglomeration of smaller
companies you know if you could talk to
a young version of you just getting
started in business know what bit of
advice would you offer number one be
totally honest tell the truth
work hard and that's a good start
and that's what you did right well I've
always been very honest in every respect
that we know how made a lot of mistakes
but never one of being dishonest and
hard work certainty is important and I
found harder your work the luckier you
get yeah you know a lot of people who
aren't in business might look to you and
say you're so successful that you must
not have made many mistakes oh I don't
know anybody that's made as many
mistakes as I have but the key is to try
to fix it and move on learn from them
learn hopefully I made the same mistake
more than once like I've already done
this why am i doing let me ask you about
your own health I mean you're in the
category of most risk right now for
covin 19 I am does it worry you
no no but I I'm following the rules the
best I can
mm-hmm do you know people who have
become sick anyone in your family or
nobody in my family and I can't say I do
know anybody this could tracted the
virus when you look at other places like
Italy or New York City or Montreal or
Montreal you know it's really do you
feel fortunate that we're in DC well I
think I think that John Horgan and the
government BC government have done a
very good job
and that took the right public health
decisions at the right No I think if you
just look at the numbers yeah British
Columbia is done very well what do you
think the biggest lesson business will
learn from this that's a good question
I think it depends on what kind of
business you're in but I think it's
important to be more conservative than
more aggressive and the approaches you
take to do the the risk probably I'm
using the wrong words here but I think
that that when something like this that
happens that nobody's ever seen anything
like it
before that when people start to talk
about that that are experts
it pays probably people like me or
anybody else to pay a lot more attention
to the experts or people that understand
these kinds of things better than then
normally you would well who did you turn
to when you started to see what was
happening in all firs China and then
Italy and Iran and then New York who did
you look to for leadership who did you
look to for expertise on how to make
decisions well we just listen to turn on
the television to your station and see
what the health officer has to save for
my area yeah because it's very different
here than it is in downtown Montreal and
I guess each division of your company
would have to look at their particular
jurisdiction well we have a people that
we have people we have employees in
Montreal and and the headquarters of the
company some are in in Quebec and some
are not but we still have people but it
pays to listen to people that know more
about what's going on than you do yeah I
do
yeah that's what my lesson I guess in
life that I keep learning over and over
is listen to the people that Nora but
know
more about what's going on than what you
think you do
or I do well that's a lot of humility
right not everyone has that well I'm
just telling you ask me why I said I'm
giving you the answer good melody it's a
good thing to have I mean we have you
know there are people in positions of
great power who don't have that well
right this is just a hypothetical
question if you had to choose between
living in the United States right now
we're living in Canada in this pandemic
where would you prefer to be I don't
have an answer for that because it's the
region's that certainly New York City is
very different than living in North
Dakota
or I guess what I'm getting at is the
political leadership like a lot of the
well I'm very happy to be a very
fortunate to be a Canadian just being in
such close proximity to the u.s. is a
quote or bad for business
oh no it's from a business point of view
it's been very positive for us to be
close to the United States yeah and
we've been very fortunate because we've
the Americans are very good when it
comes to business generally speaking and
they're very competitive and certainly
the Americans have been very positive
for our company and and the we were
there a lot this might be a you know you
can say this is a dumb question and
don't answer it
what's the best thing about being rich I
don't know what do you mean you know No
well I Drive I live in the same house
that I had I live next door to a house
that that I bought for $36,500 the house
I'm Anna I bought for a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars at the time
still in it and I'm driving a pickup
truck
so I owe a lot of money
you don't you do oh absolutely
if you build a business but you don't
have money you have to borrow the money
yeah but the trouble was boring the
money's you gotta pay it back and then
if the bank's get trust in you or other
people they'll help you book loan you
some money when you for opportunities
the main thing is to be honest and pay
your pay your bills back so what is it
about having built your business that's
so successful that you're that keeps you
getting up every morning well I can't
wait to get up in the morning because I
like going to work if you like your work
well that's I don't know anything more
fun than what I do and you want to keep
building right you're never static
like you're always looking you know I to
the neck I have always believed that
that it's important to continue to grow
your business and that's what we're
doing still doing ok so what's the worst
thing about having money I want it and
what say being rich but what's the worst
thing well we have a we have a
foundation that gives money away and do
we have people here that we take
requests and then we have a committee
that decides where we give the money and
we support different causes and and so
we have a group that decides where we
try to to help things that people that
are disadvantaged whether it's in Haiti
this in some of these poor countries or
whether it's hospitals or whether it's
other things we supported people in in
overseas so we've been very blessed to
be able to do that
you don't have to do that part why why
is it important for for business leaders
to be philanthropic to give back well I
could only speak about us I can't talk
about it okay anybody else my dad always
taught me from the time I grew up for
heat my first allowance was fifty cents
and then my dad said to me now I want
you to give five cents out of the 50 to
the collection plate of the church
because that was called tithing in the
Old Testament so I was always taught to
tithe which I still do to this day you
do you're very generous
yeah well I followed what my mother I
had good I was an only child we didn't
have anybody but I couldn't have had
better parents and you've particularly
been generous in the area of health care
hospital well with we the reason we do
that is because whether you're having
money or you're poor everybody needs
health care sooner or later and I know
you said you loved coming to work there
are a lot of people who reach a point in
life where they think okay I'm gonna
take a little break maybe even retire is
retire like a dirty word I don't know I
I just did it just doesn't appeal to me
that at this stage of the game but
nothing wrong with retiring a lot of
people do and it's the right thing to do
in my case I've always owned too much
money I had to keep working to give to
make sure I can make my papers just like
the rest of us and what do you find is
the most awkward thing about this
pandemic about the world we're living in
now is like I know you like to meet
personally with a lot of the your staff
right a lot of individually and
personally and has that been very
awkward for you two to maneuver in this
pandemic nope
we I still go to where I need to go I'm
careful and follow the rules to the best
I can
I've heard you drop in on like save on
food
why do you do that why do you just drop
by well because I dropped by to see what
how the customers are doing how the the
people are getting along their employees
and and talked to the customers and and
no I I'm very interested in how we can
do things better
hmm and there's no you're not gonna stop
that because of a virus well I'm gonna
I'm gonna follow the rules I'm staying
home like at night I go home and we're
instead of going out for dinner right I
go home cooking at home more oh I'm home
a lot I haven't been home this much for
I can't remember all right mr. Patterson
we so appreciate your taking the time
well thank you for for coming and visit
us sing today